for those of us who love shonen anime
it's all about the power growth and
action what naturally makes or breaks a
shonen anime is its fight scenes part of
the big three including naruto and
bleach one piece two comes with its
plethora of fights as a shonen fan we
live from fight to fight the characters
victories are our victories and their
failures too are also ours nothing can
be more satisfying than watching a fight
scene whether we're caught up in a power
surge or a desperate reversal of fortune
so for today's video here are the top 10
fights in the one piece so far
[Music]
we start with some nostalgia luffy
versus arlon
early in the series before the straw
hats crossed the ground line luffy faces
arlong in a fight for nami's freedom an
arrogant fish man who considers humans
to be inferior arlong wreaks
considerable damage on the straw hats
with his rapidly regenerating shark
teeth and pure physical strength
amplified more so when underwater at
number 10 this fight is as emotionally
charged as it is powerful arlong's long
sword giribachi is rendered useless and
luffy demolishes arlong park along with
its owner in one swift blow
next up at number nine the straw hats go
up against the zombie oars
while luffy is off looking for moria the
straw hats take it upon themselves to
fight ores who proves more than a
handful undeterred the crew put off some
of the most effortless and creative
attacks it's a rare joy to see the straw
hats work so well as a team when in
almost every other case there are
fighting solo even when maurya enters
ore's guts and the straw hats seem to be
fighting a losing battle they never give
up using all they must analyze and find
awesome's weakness which turns out to be
his right arm with sunrise around the
corner the straw hats have bought just
enough time for nightmare luffy to save
the day
[Music]
[Music]
in the eighth spot luffy fights his
first warlord of the sea crocodile in
the kingdom of alabasta
a man who's eaten the sansan fruit
crocodile is by all accounts invincible
more so because alabaster is all desert
not only do luffy's attacks fail to hit
crocodile the villain leaves our hero
close to death not once but twice this
fight stands out for the sheer
persistence with which luffy goes after
the baroque works head honcho to the
point of using his own blood to counter
crocodile sand attacks luffy stays on
the offensive all the way through even
when he's grazed by crocodiles poison
hook he doesn't succumb to the scorpion
venom that should have left him
paralyzed a running theme throughout the
series this time too luffy is fighting
for his nakama princess vivi in this
case even the cold-blooded crocodile
can't help but eventually be impressed
by luffy's resolve to surpass him to
protect his friends right before the
young pirate blows him up to the sky
defeated
[Applause]
coming in at number seven are the only
two lieutenants to make the ranks of the
supernovas
[Music]
[Music]
if you haven't guessed already it's
zorro vs killer or rather killers
deranged alter ego gamazo the man slayer
not surprisingly this is no simple sword
fight for one the two men have five
blades between them gamonzo matching
zorro's three sword play with a pair of
giant sights slashing and swinging to
mortally wound if not kill the two
opponents never give their blades a rest
that means we're in for a super fast
supercharged encounter that leaps off
the ground and leaves the air pulsing
blood flows hot and free in the pristine
white snow that gently envelops ringo a
picturesque region in wano in a
well-matched fight zoro still shows us
why he deserves to take on the mantle of
the world's greatest showman having a
side pierce's chest doesn't deter him
from dispatching his challenger to hell
with one last heavenly attack
one piece may be one of the biggest
anime out there but do you know that it
can't be watched legally in some places
luckily for you today's sponsor has
something to say about it introducing
expressvpn the number one vpn service in
the world just like the new world
browsing the internet these days without
a vpn is actually quite dangerous people
out to do no good have gotten better at
the whole data stealing thing and a vpn
will be your number one buddy in the
most basic sense a vpn is a program that
helps mask your identity and location
you know what this means right now you
can pretend to be somewhere you're not
and access the services available to
that region
so now you can follow one piece and
never miss a beat legally at that just
go to netflix open up expressvpn and
click on the canada server boom now you
can watch your favorite pirates in one
piece without any pop-ups and ads you've
got to experience it yourself so i'll be
giving you a hand all you have to do is
go to expressvpn.com
vinnie tube to get your first three
months free or you could check the link
in the description box in store
expressvpn now it's gonna be the best
decision you'll ever make
and the list keeps getting crazier as at
number six we have the rumble rumble
fruit user nl fighting rubberman luffy
[Music]
in the idyllic sky island of sky pear n
out reigns supreme as god with his
lightning manipulation powers and
mastery of mantra or observation haki
which allows him to predict his
opponent's next move but luffy's rubber
abilities make him nl's natural enemy
and capable of negating his lightning
bolts and enraged nl releases his most
powerful attack but the outcome is clear
by now luffy pulverizes nl bringing the
fight to a ringing end
the most heartbreaking fight on this
list we have two friends luffy and usop
facing off at number five
[Music]
the catalyst is luffy's decision to call
time on their beloved ship the going
merry usop doesn't take the news well
mata's escalate to the point where usop
challenges his captain to a duel with
both staking their pride as men on it
the two begin to fight each other in all
sincerity and luffy in the beginning
gets caught up in usof's pace knowing
all his weaknesses the long-nosed straw
hat fights earnestly with shuriken
caltraps and an ingenious use of an
impact dial source from skypier however
nursing serious injuries inflicted on
him earlier by the frankie family usopp
is left unconscious after failing to
dodge a direct strike from luffy as the
rest of the crew members look on
mortified even mary seems to be crying
at this harrowing scene trying to
contain his tears luffy leaves the ship
to usopp and walks away leaving his
friend in a crumpled heap this is the
moment our carefree hero realizes what
being a captain of a ship truly means
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
no top 10 fight list is complete without
the luffy duffy haki spectacle which
makes the cut at number four
what begins as a two versus one fight is
left to luffy to settle after doffy
incapacitates law with both opponents
wielding the same conqueror as haki the
level of power and destruction is off
the charts deep crimson flames leap and
explode each time the two tangled but
knowing luffy he never disappoints under
pressure and so gear fourth is revealed
fighting into his forearm luffy's upper
body expands and his armament haki
gleams a dangerous red accompanied by
kabuki dramatics bounce man is the most
visually striking of luffy's level ups
in the end it's luffy's king kong gun
against doffy's haki enhanced 16 holy
bullets god thread and we all know who
emerges victorious
with no haki a much stronger opponent
and a desperate desire to save robin
luffy's fight with rob lucci is next to
number three
[Music]
having declared war on the world
government at any lobby the straw hats
appear stronger and more confident but
before they can reach robin they must
get past the cp9 agents the toughest of
the lot fours on luffy's plate luci a
leopard human hybrid proves a formidable
opponent up against luchi's body
hardening technique the captain of the
straw hat struggles to keep up just with
his second gear a fierce battle leads to
luffy unveiling gear third blowing up
his arm into a gigantic bone balloon he
smashes luchi through a wall and onto a
marine battleship but luffy can only use
gear third for a minute shrinking to the
size of a child after his time is up
luchi proves far too strong for luffy
who is knocked senseless and seems to be
out for the count that's till usopp
throws down his soulgate king mask and
urges luffy to stand up and fight back a
moment the sense shivers down our spines
it's the first time usop has faced luffy
as himself after their fight spurred on
by usopp luffy keeps standing till he
eventually knocks out luci in an
impossible turn of fortune
[Music]
donuts yes it's the sweet general sharla
katakuri versus luffy in the runners-up
spot
[Applause]
big mom's second son is a master of
conqueror's haki and has a devil fruit
ability like luffy's but what sets him
apart is his observation haki which
allows him to see a little into the
future this means he can dodge luffy's
attacks with ease convinced that luffy
can't defeat him he lets his guard down
to have tea and donuts in seclusion only
for the straw hats captain to gatecrash
his little party and expose his face
which is a closely guarded secret rage
gives way to grudging admiration as
katakuri acknowledges luffy's tenacity
and the two resume their fight this time
as equals but what makes it a truly
worthy contender on this list is that it
serves as a window to the characters of
both fighters when luffy's impaled by
katakuri's spear due to his sister's
intervention the swede general reveals
his gentleman warrior side by stabbing
himself and uncovering his face to make
the fight fair and at the very end when
he falls on his back for the very first
time in a fight it's in tribute to luffy
whom he now considers his first real
challenge a war moment plays out as
luffy returns the favor covering up his
fallen rival's face
that brings us to the top prize and
number one is luffy law kid zorro and
killer taking on not one but two yonkos
in the ongoing wanna work
having finally reached the roof of
onigima the five challengers have an
impossible job on their hands defeat
kaido and big mom who have unfortunately
formed an unlikely alliance it's twice
the trouble and double the danger the
young ones who make up almost half of
the notorious rookie group called the
supernovas do start off strong they come
out all guns blazing putting their
biggest moves on display and showing
incredible results kaido takes a massive
hit from luffy and is knocked out early
on in the fight big mom playing a
supporting role also has her attacks
thwarted with his flashy weapons and
extravagant attacks this fight between
two of the greatest pirate alliances is
all about shock and awe it manages to
keep the audience on the edge of their
seats and wondering what's about to come
next while every player in the melee is
outstanding zorro deserves a special
shout out the ever dependable straw
hat's crew member not only saves his
captain from certain death but also
dares to leave a gaping wound on kaido's
dragon body with his newly inherited
sword since the action is far from over
and the last stills teased kaido being
provoked into unveiling a new and
dangerous human beast form the question
on everyone's mind is will the five
challengers get out of this alive
victory i'm afraid is still a far away
dream not that we should ever stop
dreaming
and that's it for the 10 best fights in
one piece let me know if your favorite
fights made the list and leave a comment
for anything else you'd like to say
press like if you enjoyed the video and
do subscribe to my channel for more
anime content and top 10s see you soon